beneath the glitter and glamour of Hong
Kong they're staggering inequality and a
crippling housing crisis there'd been
months of turmoil and demands for
democracy the violence has hit Hong
Kong's reputation and economy but the
authorities are blaming the unrest on
one of their most dirty secrets the
scandal of the coffin home dwellers many
of them are deeply ashamed of their
circumstances and asked us not to
identify them they're part of an army of
Hong Kong is living below the poverty
line in the world's most expensive city
where affordable housing is out of reach
to many this tiny home has been built in
the gap between the lift shaft and the
supporting walls and the family and
their six-month-old baby boy basically I
live on this beg together they've been
here for four years and for this they
pay the equivalent of around 1,500
British pounds a month it's a struggle
for survival and the protests have hit
both the Hong Kong economy as a whole
but this families pay packet - do you
think the protest will end up with you
getting better housing I don't know I
don't know but when he carries on like
this I'll lose my job very soon and I'll
have no money to buy food
but there are plenty worse off than him
all of these are homes top and bottom
they can just about fit one narrow
single mattress here's the law not even
long enough for someone to lie down in
and there are 15 of these in this one
room take a look inside one of them it's
not even 2 square metres a home which
will cost several hundred pounds per
month to rent and most of the people
here earn very little and rely on
housing subsidies
this is the dark underbelly of Hong Kong
and understandably it's very difficult
for outsiders to get access to them we
only managed it by building up trust
with some of the residents there are an
estimated 200,000 people living like
this in Hong Kong and the fight on the
streets for votes is said to be central
to bolstering the human rights here
which should lead to better living
conditions they don't think the
situation now we can have it she's chief
executive to be represent us so they
think the universal suffrage is so
fundamental for Hong Kong to solve
different social problems the coffin
home dwellers themselves feel helpless
and forgotten by the government and the
protesters this man's been waiting for
better housing for ten years and lived
in this box for three why don't they
ever mention the housing problem in the
democracy protests there aren't enough
homes and people like me are just being
ignored Hong Kong's leader prefers to
focus on these social issues rather than
dealing with the demands for democracy
on the streets which are at the heart of
the protests and the city's poor are
mostly voiceless and vulnerable Alex
Crawford Sky News Hong Kong